hello and welcome to this video
FM kites GFE it's that no one okay okay
then you get a real bang Kok eminent
they play those lame sidelines so often
okay
yeah b6 is a good line for white I mean
good good in terms of solid and okay I
don't think it's great or anything yeah
yeah Black has to know this idea okay
for Queen to be seven I get the Bishop
to b5 this is a an important idea
[Music]
maybe maybe can win a pawn in the
process but shouldn't be all them all
that's terrible
there should be five rupee three I have
Queen c7 okay and quite remember as
remember and throw me knowledge she read
not not a theoretical position anyway
Queen B 3 it's a little bit irritating
him I don't quite know what my
compensation is okay just let's see yeah
this kind of thing just looks like a
very decent Benoni
oh wow really what about this you play
what look a form it looks like a funny
book probably okay for you then I'm
taking and the rook is on C form this is
a very shaky center root before as a
threat now that essentially wins
material if he just allows it like that
I don't quite know how he prevents it
what is he doing here like 93 or
something I'm still going before it's
some Center is very shaky are the king
oh it's so good huh threatening night f2
and 95 yeah this is a good thing I keep
repeating this about this opening if
things go wrong for why I think you're
really really wrong I don't I don't know
what he still hasn't move here that you
can play no I mean I wouldn't lose this
stuff no I like the one in house okay
so I can check here I mean it's good
anyway but let's I wanted to check I
have not checked five of course and now
just night before or this is so dreadful
maybe that's something else but yeah
this question it's it's just good take
the big center pole and now um the chick
[Music]
many things are good here check the
check assist is fine I would like to
pick up the pawn just the full pawn if
possible
Knight f2 and then Knight 2 D 3 what
just rupee 5 yeah Ruby 5 before I don't
quite okay I can do this and take it can
take just 85 okay this is good actually
b3 ok fiber checkmate that would be a
nice form okay so what is the cleanest
way to do this maybe this and then take
check take both ones wait just a second
this King c4 but I have eat six home
yeah got you six that's your [ __ ] c4
is not not especially great technically
speaking now I know here would like to
get the Knight to e4 like f5 and Knight
to e4 check
it's almost made almost check there's no
checkmate yeah that's a shame
[Music]
almost almost made check no I'm done
during the night I belong in the night
oh my god okay I'm just completely
immersed in in the position like yeah
how do I win most beautifully now and
then all of a sudden have a piece down
amazing amazing
from this in this game to not win it was
quite amazing okay I'm a blunder foon
item it's also the only way to not win
you have to really blunder blunder big
material check check
check black present you know I just
wondered the night yeah it was such a
terrible position check that was simply
too immersed and in checking how how
check is the nicest way to win the check
and you can of course play basically
everything just not give away the knife
Jim yeah there's not much generalize
ready what I did here was absolutely
terrible from here this position is shot
is borderline and after that I'm
basically winning him shiny quicker ways
to to win but check it was definitely
definitely I will be one is stronger
okay
do you really
check check missing from aids and what's
really close really close yeah maybe
just ninety seven is easier but here you
can really do whatever 93 as the engine
suggests just don't manda just to
blunder and in the opening and what you
can state here this line is bad for
white this is this line but it sometimes
played it's useful to know Queen before
Queen d7 as we have seen it just leads
to a good position for black you should
just not blunder Knights yeah
then the other guy can play however
badly he wants night given for nothing
is too much thanks for watching